Gabe founded his first company when he
was 18 and then sold at 21 and followed
by that he launched kal finder where he
bootstrap that business 225 million
dollars in sales without bringing in a
cent of outside funding after exiting
Cal finer gave started up shipped which
is a growth stage accelerated program to
help startup scaled sales teams and
months as opposed to years in the past
six months I've shipped graduates have
raised over 52 million dollars at
funding I first heard about Gabe when
Tim Ferriss retweeted this amazing blog
post about how he bootstrapped Cal find
her rent when I saw it I knew we had to
have him here so today Gabe's gonna give
the lowdown on how he's been able to
help team scale their sale sales teams
so please give a warm welcome for Gabe
hey good afternoon so my name is Gabe
founder of up shift partners we help
startups scale sales and make money so
like many of you I'm a entrepreneur and
I'm here today to share some of the
lessons that I learned going from an
idea in a spare bedroom to a
multi-million dollar company without
ever having to raise a penny of outside
funding to say that my journey here was
unique I think would be a kind of an
understatement so didn't go to an Ivy
League school in fact dropped out of
college never raised a penny of VC funds
bootstrapped it on my own credit cards
and I also grew up on a hippie commune
in Northern California where we didn't
have electricity we didn't have a
television we didn't have internet and I
didn't have a whole lot of examples of I
guess successful entrepreneurs in fact
that the only entrepreneurs that I knew
on the hippie commune were farmers
but yet eight years ago in in the heart
of Silicon Valley I started a tech
company without having an email address
or a computer so if I can do it anyone
can so get the reason that I'm here
today is really to share some little
lessons that I learned and in the hopes
that you don't make all the same
mistakes that I do or that I did so
these are really three powerful lessons
that I learned unfortunately the hard
way the first one was really the power
of doing more with less because we
didn't have a lot of money in the bank
and we had to focus the second thing is
making the system the hero from the very
beginning and the third is to let data
drive decisions so I'll dig into these
things a little bit more throughout my
talk I also wanted to give everyone here
an opportunity to just listen and learn
so actually wrote an article on exactly
what I'm talking about today including
all the fine details of it and it's
available at upshift partners comm slash
dispatch so you'll be able to access the
entire article said I encourage you to
just you know put pens and computers
down and just sit back and relax
so doing more with less
we started our companies just simply
with our credit cards to be able to get
our company launched so we didn't have a
whole lot of cash in the bank and
fortunately we were able to get it off
the ground and we're able to get it up
to about three million dollars in annual
sales and then we just hit this plateau
where it was like no matter how much
brute force we were using the the
top-line numbers just weren't growing
and I can remember this one day sitting
down and and you know we were pretty
ambitious we wanted to double the
revenue of the company every single year
meka I remember sitting down actually
looking at the numbers and thinking oh
like I'm gonna have to hire three
times as many salespeople in the next
like four months to get this growth and
although I was willing to do that like
I'm I'm a hustler at heart I knew that
got it I just don't want that to be the
first option I knew that in my gut like
there had to be a better way than just
simply brute force and so the next
morning I came into the office and I
printed off our entire customer list at
at this point we actually had computers
so it was it was amazing so printed off
the customer list and sat down with it
and actually started looking through all
the customers and and how much they were
spending on with our platform and I
something caught my eye I found that
there was these two customers that were
spending about ten times the amount of
revenue in the same period of time as
our average customer and it got my
attention kind of the light bulb started
to go off and I started to ask around
and ask the different team members you
know why are these people spending so
much more than everyone else and
honestly nobody had a really good answer
for me so I went on Elance and I hired
an Internet researcher to basically take
our top ten customers and our bottom ten
customers and look at like all the other
attributes that we didn't currently have
so you know we had name and address and
that kind of basic information but what
we didn't have was things like how many
counties did these business cover how
long had there
website been up or when did it when was
it most recently updated what were they
doing as far as online advertising what
were they doing on social and we got the
results back a few days later and I can
say that 98% of it didn't tell us
anything but it was that 2% that was
actually really valuable we saw these
similarities between the customers that
were these kind of 10x customers and
also similarities in the like the bottom
10 customers and and I started to look
at it and say wow like in order to
double the company I only need to get 20
of these customers as opposed to 200
other customers and and I always
described myself as being productively
lazy so I look for the fastest way that
also requires the least amount of effort
in order to kind of achieve the goals so
I started looking at it and said okay I
went back on to Elance hired another
researcher and said I want you to find a
hundred people that match this exact
same criteria that are that these to 10x
companies match a few days later we get
this list back we did as they said okay
we're gonna go after this really small
list of super high-value customers the
first thing we need to do is get their
attention they don't even know about us
so what we did was we designed this
really clever campaign where basically
and this is I think what where my my
hustle side came in is basically said
we're gonna hit these companies from
every single side for 12 weeks straight
and we're gonna get all of their
attention so what we did is we sent out
a little direct mail piece with kind of
a clever gift and a clever handwritten
note that got their attention we sent
that out every single week and then we
would call behind the direct mail
campaign so we sent out the first one
waited for the phones to ring nothing
happened sent out the second one waited
for the phones to ring nothing happened
four weeks go by and my co-founder and
and our salespeople are like yeah that
was just another one of Gabe's crazy
ideas that didn't really work
and it's a Wednesday afternoon and and
my cellphone rings and I pick it up and
guy says yeah this Gabe yes says this is
Steve you got my attention what can you
do for me I was so caught off guard that
I had to tell me I was in the middle of
a meeting and call him back and I looked
up his information this is the CEO of a
four billion dollar company that has
just called me on my cell phone so end
up setting a meeting with Steve week
five get another phone call
two weeks later get two more phone calls
play it out
four months later we'd signed over two
million dollars in new business then
when we tallied up what we spent in
marketing it was less than two thousand
dollars the most amazing marketing
return you could ever imagine and what I
learned in doing that was was a couple
couple big things first off and this is
more for people that that don't yet have
customers is focus on customers that
they kind of meet three criteria they
have the most pervasive urgent and
costly need the second thing is if
you're already running and you already
have a customer base look at the top ten
in the bottom ten and actually spend the
time dig into all the attributes and try
to understand what makes those people
the top ten or the bottom ten don't just
kind of use this spray-and-pray approach
and then in the words of notorious b.i.g
Mo Money mo problems the reality is you
know if we had ten million dollars in
the bank I wouldn't have been forced to
be that creative so money buys a lot of
things it doesn't necessarily buy
creativity and it doesn't certainly
doesn't buy hustle so lesson two was
really about making the system the hero
when I was in college my I would say my
first job after making deli sandwiches
where actually got fired from that's
when I decided that I should be a CEO my
my kind of first real world experience I
got an internship where I got to
run my own house painting company I know
you're all thinking wow what a sexy job
but over the course of a summer what I
did was actually go literally go around
and knock on doors and get leads if
people want to get painting work done
and then do estimates and and you know
and and a booking work and running a
house painting company what I learned in
doing that was to really core things one
was the power of hustle like knocking on
10,000 doors before I ever turned 21
getting chased by dogs and whatnot
and the second thing was really the
power of a good system and so I took
that into the next company that we
started so we started my last company
kal finder literally without email
addresses or computers but we knew the
power of a system so we wanted to test
the concept and what we did was we took
four yellow notepads four pens and we
wrote down a really simple script that
we were gonna test on homeowners to see
if they would want to get connected with
home service professionals and we took
those basic scripts out and we took our
yellow notepads we went and knocked on
doors cuz that's what we knew how to do
we didn't know how to build software or
anything and first day we get back and
and we'd collected about 10 names and
phone numbers people that wanted work
done it's pretty surprising the next day
we followed a similar process so what we
did was we looked in the yellow pages
and tried to find contractors that had
the biggest ads because we knew they
were spending money and we wrote down a
script and kind of a pitch that we would
use then we went to their offices and we
pitched them on the concept and said hey
listen would you be interested in
getting homeowners that want to get work
done on their houses they said yes we
said well how much would you pay the
classic hustler move and they said 80
bucks so we asked him if they had a
photocopy machine and we took these
yellow notepads and we went into their
office and we made a copy and we got
them to write us a check for 800 bucks
to buy the ten names and that was like
our seed capital and then we went to the
next contractors office and we followed
the same script and asked him how much
they'd be willing to pay they said a
hundred bucks so we did the same thing
made another thousand bucks
third contractor we asked the same
questions says 120 bucks make 1,200 more
bucks so make three thousand bucks in
our first day
we're like fist-pumping and thinking
we're gonna be billionaires at
the end of the month but what we what we
were able to do is we took those same
scripts and the next week we went to
college campus and we said ask college
kids if they wanted to make 30 bucks an
hour
took them out the next week got 40 leads
using that same script followed the same
process with contractors and we just
rinsed and repeated we made the system
better every single week and that's what
enabled us to go from me being the first
salesperson to ten salespeople to 25 to
50 without ever raising any outside
funding so my advice is make the system
the hero from the very beginning you
know when you look at companies like
uber or lyft they're expanding into all
these new markets and they have a
playbook for everything and so it's
never too early to start building your
playbook the second thing is if you're
doing something more than twice it needs
to be documented there needs to be a
checklist otherwise you're always gonna
do that task or somebody else is going
to do a shitty job of it the third thing
is set is scheduled to iterate
especially if you're early in the game
there's probably some really simple
things that you're doing every week
whether it be having conversations with
customers or trying to get your first
sales like start then build a playbook
and then iterate on it every single week
so lesson three and I would say this was
one of the most painful lessons that I
learned and I've had to learn it a
couple of times but but I want to share
a story with you there was a pivotal
moment in my last company so we've taken
the company and we at the time we were
going after kind of a small business
segment so it was very much like a high
volume approach and we had built a sales
organization 250 sales people which is a
incredibly challenging thing to do and
it's also kind of like herding cats
imagine 50 salespeople in one room it's
it's kind of a nightmare so we had built
a company 250 salespeople we had 4x the
number of deals that we were doing even
a short period before and we had had
about six months into
that and and started to look at the
numbers and it was like I remember this
like rock dropping into my belly and and
realizing that we had made like a
massive mistake and only six of those
sales people were actually performing
when we looked at all the numbers what
had happened is that we hired all these
people very excited signing lots of
deals but all the customers were
churning out we had really like bad
customer satisfaction ratings so we
looked at these six and these six sales
people were just they were killing it
they were doing incredibly well and we
looked at the bank account and again we
didn't have a whole lot of buffer and if
we looked at the numbers we said if we
continue on this path we'll be bankrupt
in 45 to 60 days and I like it still
hurts when I think about it but we had
to make a massive course correction this
is one of the most difficult things I've
ever done in business we let go of 42
people the next week these are people
that had given like their lives to
helping grow the company and it was just
heartbreaking and what we did is we went
back to the drawing board and we looked
at all the data from all the six from
the six people that were being really
successful and what we found is that
they were going after a different kind
of customer type and they had a like a
certain kind of timing that they were
using to get in touch with them and so
what we did was again going back to
lesson two we started to build a recipe
around what these six people were doing
play that forward and we had actually
doubled the revenue of the company
without hiring another salesperson over
the next 12 months so one of the most
difficult decisions that I ever made but
if I let my ego get in the way of
actually making an objective decision
based on data I wouldn't be up here on
this stage today talking to you about
our success so what did I learn from
this I learned to always let data drive
decisions this is something that's just
absolutely critical for startups there's
so many moving parts and so
any challenges that you have to let data
drive decisions and if the highest-paid
person in the room is is purely relying
on gut you're gonna get yourself into
trouble pretty quickly and you might end
up down a road that's really hard to
course-correct from the second thing is
doing the best to remove ego from
decision-making so our question always
is you know what does the data say not
what do you think what's your opinion on
it what does the data say and then the
third thing is to manage by the numbers
and this is oftentimes a transition for
startups from the early craziness where
you're just like throwing spaghetti
against the wall seeing what sticks and
transitioning out of that and actually
building a sustainable company and
having that kind of transparency to run
the company by the numbers so you know
this this last lesson only to harp on it
but it was one that was kind of a
culmination for me and it's an area in
in going through that process and having
to actually let go of all those people
and also to rebuild the company what I
learned was obviously that the power of
focus and doing more with less
I also learned to to let the system be
the hero and build the system around
what's working and then also to let data
drive decisions so now I I wanted to
take a little bit of time to answer some
questions either on my own path of you
know scaling my last company or you know
what we've learned in helping seven
startups to scale sales over the last
seven months so happy to answer
questions
hey Gabe thanks for taking the time
through this today I helped Sam a little
bit with hustle calm but during the day
I'm a sales development rep at zenefits
so I thought what you said was really
interesting can you talk more about
those six people that were sort of the
outliers with in your organization what
they did differently than the other 42
that you cut off yeah so the things that
we started to notice was they they were
going after actually a different
customer segments and they were taking
more of a I would call like a sniper
approach as opposed to like the ak-47
approach so these people if our average
sales person they were calling on SMB is
right so it was a big volume game and
the height of things we were doing about
20,000 outbound calls a day and these
sales people were doing like five calls
a day each but yet the people that they
were talking to were highly qualified
and also had the potential to spend a
lot more on the platform and they also
said great expectations so we didn't
have churn with those people so that's
those are the kind of the attributes
that we found with those salespeople so
were they doing mostly email outreach or
like how are they getting they were
doing email and then following up with a
phone call and so that was like the
approach that seemed to be working for
them cool thank you cool
any other questions
please come down okay nope okay all
right thanks very much Gabe